hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on Falana again today we got
a little bit of a different video I
wanted to talk about gladiator and how
you can get thirty damage with his toe
stab so in my last video I had talked
about a lot of different things about
how my toe step was never doing 20
damage and a lot of people are saying
that it did but then a lot of people
were like well you're doing 20 damage in
the video and I wasn't looking at the
damage and apparently that that was true
I actually was doing 20 damage so I kind
of looked through it and kind of saw
which you know what was correct and I
figured out that you can do 10 damage
with the regular toe step you can do 20
if you add haymaker and you can do 30 if
you add fear itself I've tried to add
stuff like roar of the crowd and deadly
together and all that stuff but deadly
only works for light attacks and heavy
attacks and stuff and skewers not the
toe stab and fear itself actually
doesn't seem to do anything it just
keeps it at 20 for some reason so I'm
not really sure what's going on there
I'm unaware if you can pair some attack
buff like the ones in elimination with
fear itself and it does even more but to
my knowledge that doesn't really work
and I think it's capped out at 30 but
I'm completely fine with getting 30
damage on a really fast move so we're
gonna be kind of exploiting that today
and just having a little bit of fun with
the move and seeing how much damage we
can do and how annoying it can really be
so as always like the baby do enjoy guys
subscribe for new let's get started now
obviously the one negative to having
this much damage is that if somebody has
some type of damage resistance or
anything like that it's going to negate
the amount of damage that you're going
to be doing I remember I had I think I
think I had everything on haymaker and
fear itself but somebody had some type
of shield and I wasn't doing as much
damage as before but not many people
will have that on for their feet so it's
really not that big of a deal and even
if you can't get the 30 damage getting
20 damage itself on a haymaker
with the haymaker feet and it for being
a toe step is pretty [ __ ] bonkers
regardless and obviously is you guys
know if you watched a lot of my
gameplays specifically you know I like
to play some support type of gladiator
where if I'm in a two-on-one situation
with a teammate my main objective isn't
really to do a lot of damage it's really
just to be the guy the toe step so that
the opponent can't get any diff
defensive maneuvers and it just gets
free hits
so I'm obviously gonna be completely
tearing the shaman up easy toast add
clips Oh buddy Oh I walked I went the
wrong direction I went the wrong
direction it's a shame it's a big shame
it's a big shame yeah I kind of panicked
a little bit I didn't mean to go to the
left I had a feeling he would thrown out
of stamina heavy but I was just
ever since JJ's released with his out of
stamina moves being bugged I've still
never been completely sure on what the
timing is for those out of stamina
heavies because I member back when he
first released it was really bugged so
I've never still like caught up to that
type of [ __ ] so I I just don't bother
sometimes
let me see if I could really provide a
good example of what I'm trying to
explain if this are Musha would help me
stage is getting really good at dodging
the toe stab which I mean it's really
not that hard to be fair but yeah so
right now we're in a three-on-one and I
got the haymaker feet my main objective
is just to basically keep toe stabbing
so that the JJ has not many ways of
getting damage
[ __ ] this isn't good and my team let me
down Oh buddy one more time I'm trash oh
three four three oh you know how you
know two vibes that that is a perfect
example right there as well I'm so glad
I nailed that cliff i toast step the
Nobu she she didn't have enough time to
block the incoming new Chevy
so she completely ate that for free
damage it's the biggest reason why use
the toe stepa just because of that stuff
ah [ __ ] man I'm so garbage at this game
I had a really good thing moving there
too and I [ __ ] it up this show this
shamans gonna die T on DS got all she's
dead
[Music]
excellent bro T on D last laugh is
disgusting powerful won't run the topic
of using unconventional moves and
spamming them we might as well continue
using the sprint attack and the
bamboozle because like I mean need i say
more
get the [ __ ] out of my face boy what a
[ __ ] joke
alright well you know what we do when we
hit a crash run it back
oh my god I'm actually wait I'm actually
still going hey hold up it's gonna end
now it's gonna end
[ __ ] it's as easy as that boys
we killed depression alright so if you
ever in a situation man Littlefield's
talk here write on some real [ __ ] if you
ever get into a situation where
depression hits you you know with that
heavy faint gb falls for it every time
that'll be your motivation for today
look at that range that's deadly that is
[ __ ] deadly let's deep [ __ ] that kind
of deserve that no reason for you to gb
after that now your [ __ ] he do he did it
twice
damn perfect my body was a distraction
okay toe stab 30 damage do it again
you're getting deflected oh do what I'm
like I'm a god toast and toast add it
did it's it's too easy and it's as easy
as that boys hopefully you enjoyed the
video you know we got a lot we had a lot
of [ __ ] there to show off it's pretty
fun to use this I'm out of all things
I'm actually kind of excited that the
toast that has more damage B I like the
V if we do enjoy a subscriber for new I
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
to hero updates the patch notes and the
leaks going to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out an update
that we say subscribe to channel that
guys hope you guys enjoyed this video
like I said before peace out yesterday
[Music]
you